bonjour bienvenue à La semaine verte au
Canada l'agriculture génère 10% des gaz
à effet de serre comparé à d'autres
grands secteurs comme la production
d'énergie ou encore les transports c'est
relativement peu mais qu'est-ce qui
aimait des GES en agriculture et comment
mesurer l'empreinte carbone d'une ferme
prise individuellement on est allé à la
rencontre d'agriculteurs et de
chercheurs qui se sont posés exactement
ces questions là
c'est le début de l'été chez Eric
Lapierre à Saint-Nazaire d'acte dans
Montérégie sa terre compte 400 hectares
de grandes cultures
de produire au coût le plus bas afin
d'assurer une pérennité financière mais
en gardant un emprunte environnementale
le plus basse possible
c'est là avec ce réflexion là que j'ai
commencé un peu à challenger mon
agronome
Eric m'avait déjà demandé Mélanie
j'aimerais ça calculer mes émissions GS
si mon empreinte carbone à la ferme puis
là je mets du bon avec OK comment moi
tant que conseiller comment je peux
faire ça quel outil je peux avoir pour
faire ce bilan là puis pour moi c'était
comme il avait besoin de faire des
recherches puis on va regarder avec les
années de ça mais le bord pourrait
peut-être être une
un élément à regarder il y a 20 ans à
l'époque où Mélanie Hardy étudiait en
agronomie on ne parlait pas de gaz à
effet de serre de GES à la ferme et même
aujourd'hui difficile de trouver des
repères on parle toujours
l'environnement par jour bon je disais
ok chaque petit geste compte mais le
problème c'est qu'on ne sait pas on n'a
pas d'idées on n'est pas capable de
chiffrer c'est dur de demander à
quelqu'un on dit bon faut réduire
pour ça je sais pas mais si on sait pas
notre point A comment qu'on veut réduire
se rendre un point B
l'agriculteur et son agronome croise
alors sur leur chemin agric climat un
projet financé par le ministère de
l'Environnement du Québec depuis 2017 le
but d'agriculture en fait au tout début
c'était vraiment de s'approprier ce que
ça veut dire les changements climatiques
en agriculture c'était de comprendre
quel effet cela chez les producteurs
comment ça va les affecter positivement
ou négativement puis comment s'adapter à
tout ça
rapidement les agronomes et autres
chercheurs d'agricula sont confrontés
aux questions des agriculteurs question
pour lesquelles ils ont bien peu de
réponses
est-ce que j'en ai mettant que ça des
jeux et moi je participe tu à ça puis si
oui ben ça ressemble à quoi mon bilan
est-ce que je peux faire des changements
ou de faire des choix d'entreprise qui
tiendrai compte de tout ça l'idée de
faire le bilan GES des 38 fermes
participantes s'imposent alors s'il
existe des calculateurs qui permettent
aux simples citoyens de mesurer son
empreinte carbone en quelques clics de
souris à l'échelle d'une ferme c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué parce que selon
le climat le type de sol la superficie
de la ferme les cultures les animaux
qu'on élève ou pas les résultats peuvent
être complètement différents et jusqu'à
tout récemment au Québec il n'existait
pas d'outils convivial pour mesurer
l'empreinte GES d'une ferme
[Musique]
exercice de grande revue littérature en
présence ça comme ça allez voir tout ce
qui se faisait comme recherche comme
études québécoise qui était suffisamment
validé par les Pères pour qu'on
l'utilise dans calculateur ce
calculateur a permis de produire pour la
première fois un portrait GES de ferme
dans le contexte québécois les fermes
pilotes sont comme des collaborateurs
avec nous pour utiliser un nouvel outil
puis s'assurer qu'il soit utilisable par
un grand nombre de producteurs la
consommation d'énergie c'est seulement
8% de tes émissions
ton principal en fait pose des missions
c'est vraiment les protoxyde d'azote du
sol ce jour-là Charlotte Caudron
agriculum présente le bilan carbone de
la ferme d'Eric et comme ailleurs ce
diagnostic donne lieu à certaines
surprises
Eric satanait à entendre parler du
carburant qu'il utilise dans sa
machinerie
et en réalité
8% de mon émission exactement de GS le
92 autres pour cent et ailleurs
exactement en tout début on leur posait
la question on sait c'est quoi que vous
pensez que votre poste d'édition le plus
important et puis la grande majorité pas
tous mais la grande majorité peu importe
le type de production répondait
probablement mon tracteur en écarte ça
m'a fait beaucoup de passage en chantier
puis on entend parler du transport mais
chez Eric comme dans toutes les fermes
de grandes cultures ce qui pollue le
plus c'est le sol
va démission sur la ferme c'est vraiment
le protoxyde d'azote des sols donc
faites les émissions des sols le
protoxyde d'azote est un gaz à effet de
serre méconnu et pourtant son potentiel
réchauffant et 300 fois supérieur à
celui du CO2 il est lié aux engrais
chimiques azotées et c'est l'une des
principales sources de GES pour cultiver
des grandes cultures on a besoin
d'apporter de l'azote au sol pour
pouvoir nourrir le sol nourrir les
plantes puis en fait c'est cet azote qui
peut être transformé en protoxine et
certaines plantes ont besoin de plus
d'azote que d'autres voici
Eric Lapierre en 2019 à l'époque il
cultivait encore du maïs la plante
chouchou des agriculteurs et pour cause
elle procure beaucoup de volume et se
vend à un bon prix mais depuis
l'agriculteur a complètement abandonné
cette culture
qui est énergivore ça que toutes les
sens du mot qui est énergivore en un
temps qui énergivant carburant qui est
énergivore en tête et à la surprise de
son entourage il a remplacé le maïs par
le canola il sert Montérégie on n'a pas
beaucoup de superficie en canola donc ce
nouveauté ici en tant que conseiller
aussi d'accompagner
Eric dans la culture de canonologue
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de mes
connaissances à ce sujet-là
le canola se vend plus cher que le maïs
mais il procure moins de tonnes à
l'hectare sauf qu'il se récolte beaucoup
plus tôt que le maïs ce qui donne le
temps d'implanter tout de suite une
autre culture à l'automne comme le blé
et comparé au maïs le canola est moins
gourmand en engrais et en carburant ce
qui réduit les coûts de production et
les GES dans le fond ici il y a des
apports fertilisant moins important
c'est moins énergivore comme culture que
du maïs grain
à la récolte on n'a pas besoin de faire
de séchage donc ça réduit énormément la
quantité de propane qu'on utilisait
auparavant pour sécher le maïs les
changements dans la rotation de culture
ont permis à Éric Lapierre de réduire
son empreinte carbone de 23%. tout en
nourrissant plus de gens les cultures
que tu produisent maintenant vont être
directement à destination d'alimentation
humaine alors qu'avant ça passait par
les animaux en fait je sais pas plus
pauvre je suis pas plus riche j'ai la
même capacité de remboursement en
faisant autre chose ça me permet de
redistribuer les risques
et le producteur pourrait encore
s'améliorer en diminuant davantage ses
apports de lisier par exemple le Québec
et le Canada ont d'ailleurs adopté des
cibles de réduction liées aux engrais
mais elles ne sont pas contraignantes
pour l'instant le secteur agricole n'est
pas tenu de réduire ses émissions et
pour bien des agriculteurs ce genre de
cible demeure encore bien peu concrète
on a toujours la notion d'argent c'est
simple on la connaît un geste
environnemental on n'a pas de valeur
d'association qu'on a pas ça devient
difficile d'avoir un discours cohérent à
partir du moment qu'on a aucune valeur
associée au Québec seulement les grandes
cultures occupent des centaines de
milliers d'hectares réduire ne serait-ce
qu'un peu les émissions de ces
superficie pourrait donc avoir de grands
impacts
au Canada tout comme au Québec
d'ailleurs la majorité des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en agriculture
provient des animaux plus précisément de
leur digestion et de leur déjection mais
là aussi il y a moyen de s'améliorer
à Chesterville dans le centre du Québec
le paysage est tout en relief le village
est d'ailleurs surnommé la Petite Suisse
du Québec c'est justement de ce pays qui
est originaire Robert Rossier installé
ici depuis le milieu des années 90
collines des Boissets montagneux on
avait besoin d'avoir un horizon qui
s'arrête dans le fond puis c'est ce
qu'on a trouvé en venant ici le
producteur participe au projet agricula
qui vise entre autres à faire un bilan
carbone des fermes
avec 72 vaches en lactation l’empreinte
GES ici est complètement différente de
celle d'une ferme de grande culture sans
animaux pour mon autre prise mon
musulman plus gros poste c'est la
fermentation entérique la rumination des
vaches les vaches ruines puis autrement
la gestion des fumiers quand elle rumine
les vaches produisent de façon tout à
fait naturelle du méthane un gaz à effet
de serre au pouvoir réchauffant 28 fois
supérieur au CO2 et à l'autre bout leur
fumier qui se décompose produit lui
aussi du méthane et du protoxyde d'azote
un autre puissant gaz à effet de serre
pour à plusieurs niveaux
Sylvestre Delmotte a passé au Pen fin
les données de la ferme de Robert
Rossier l'entrebout qui est quand même
assez productif donc qui produit
beaucoup de lait donc c'est sûr que
quand on calcule les émissions par kilo
de lait il est avantagé par une forte
productivité mais il est aussi une
alimentation qui fait en sorte que ces
vaches par kilos de les produits vont
avoir mettre un petit peu moins qu'une
ferme moyenne du sud du Québec en
général même si la gestion des fumiers
pèse relativement lourde dans le bilan
de Robert Rossier ça ferme se démarque
comme dans la majorité des exploitations
laitières on trouve ici une fausse à
fumier liquide dans sa gestion liquide
il va sortir son fumier de sa peau à
plusieurs reprises durant l'été il va y
avoir moins d'émission que dans une
gestion plus classique où on viderait au
printemps et à l'automne par exemple
quand on vide complètement la fosse on
diminue de beaucoup les émissions de
méthane et une partie du fumier est sous
forme solide ce qui émet près de deux
fois moins de gaz à effet de serre que
le fumier liquide l'hiver
on voit qu'il est comme un peu plus noir
un peu il est déjà un petit peu composé
déjà le fait que certaines vaches
aillent ou pâturage et que leur fumier
soit répandue naturellement aux champs
ce qui évite la période de stockage
contribue aussi à diminuer les émissions
mais là où la ferme de Monsieur réussi
un petit exploit c'est au chapitre de
ces sols il y a une autre particularité
aussi dans la ferme de Monsieur Rossier
qu'on retrouve pas partout au Québec
c'est que ces sols sont dans une
dynamique où il séquestre chaque année
davantage de carbone faut comprendre que
ok au Québec en général on cultive des
sols qui a pas si longtemps c'était des
forêts dans une forêt il y a beaucoup
plus de carbone dans le sol quand on met
en culture on vient mathématiquement
relâcher du carbone dans l'atmosphère
cette conversion vers l'agriculture et
le changement d'usage des terres a fait
en sorte que selon les régions du monde
les sols ont perdu de vin à 75% du
carbone qu'il contenait c'est la plus
importante source de gaz à effet de
serre après la combustion des énergies
fossiles mais il y a moyen de renverser
la tendance une fois dans l'atmosphère
le carbone se présente sous forme
gazeuse dans le CO2 par la photosynthèse
les plantes arrivent à l'absorber et à
relâcher de l’oxygène le carbone est
alors un magasin sous forme solide dans
les tissus végétaux dans ces sols Robert
Rossier réussit à séquestrer du carbone
entre autres grâce à ceci de vastes
prairies de foin ça fait combien de
temps que ça a été implanté
contrairement à une culture annuelle
comme le maïs le foin survit pendant
plusieurs années et ici l'agriculteur
vient même ressemer ses prairies avec un
semoir spécial pour améliorer leur
productivité ce qui me frappe c'est en
fait la durée des prairies sur cette
ferme ci parce que au Québec les
prairies donc les plans de frères qu'on
récolte qu'on fausse en général on va
lui conserver quatre ans ou 5 ans mais
ici les prairies sont conservés 10 ans
puis elle demeure productive en fait
pendant 10 ans ça c'est quelque chose
qui m'impressionne beaucoup
plus on maintient une prairie longtemps
plus on accumule de carbone dans le sol
car pour survivre ces plantes
investissent dans leurs racines
contrairement aux annuelles qui elles se
dépêchent de produire beaucoup de
graines avant l'automne au niveau du
carbone on va vraiment avoir une
différence dans la masse de Racine entre
les plantes pérennes puis les annuelles
donc si on détend les racines puis on
les pèse au niveau des plantes périnées
on va avoir en moyenne 13.5 tonnes de
matière sèches à l'hectare dans les 30
premiers centimètres de sol les plantes
annuelles produisent en moyenne 3 tonnes
de matière sèches autrement dit la masse
racinaire des plantes pérennes est au
moins quatre fois plus importante que
celle des annuelles et cela se mesure
aussi en kilomètres le maïs par exemple
produit 75000 km de racine à l'hectare
contre 260 000 km pour les plantes qui
composent le foin cette masse reste là
est toujours en renouvellement donc à
chaque année on a une partie qui se
décompose qui retourne au sol ça peut
faire beaucoup beaucoup de carbone
cumulés pour toutes les années de la
prairie depuis les années 90 les
superficie de foin ont fondu au Québec
au profit des cultures annuelles le
cheptelbovin a diminué certes mais
l'alimentation des vaches laitières a
changé elle aussi il y a des producteurs
qui ont donné de plus en plus de mailles
sans large par exemple ou de fourrage
fait à partir de culture annuelle puis
ça des avantages à certains égards mais
c'est sûr que en conséquence en cultive
moins de plantes terrines puis il faut
pas négliger l'impact que ça sur le
stock de carbone de nos sols
mais malgré toutes les bonnes pratiques
à la ferme de Robert Rossier le bilan
GES est clair la carbone neutralité dont
on entend parler n'est pas à portée de
main les émissions sont encore trop
importantes
mais
là c'est pour ça que je me suis dit 2050
la carbonate alité il y aura du travail
il y aura du travail
[Rires]
si on veut atteindre la carbonatalité ça
veut dire qu'il faut falloir d'une part
réduire énormément nos émissions et
aujourd'hui avec les connaissances qu'on
a il y a quand même une limite à ce
qu'on est capable de faire donc on peut
être un peu plus vertueux mais pas
nécessairement sans compromettre
d'autres objectifs comme de produits
pour nourrir les gens sans non plus
nécessairement affecter la rentabilité
économique de l'entreprise je pense que
produit que l'on crée que ça soit un
objet ou de la nourriture on a déjà une
activité humaine une activité
anthropique qui crée des GES on peut pas
faire d'agriculture sans émettre aucun
gaz à effet de serre
faire un bilan carbone permet tout de
même d'entrevoir des pistes de réduction
une façon de diminuer les GES ici serait
de réduire le nombre d'animaux de
remplacement et donc la quantité
d'estomac qui produisent du méthane pour
90 vaches actuellement on a à peu près
35 à 40 tours qu'on élève par année puis
c'est trop parce que on a calculé qu'à
25 par année
on est correct mais en agriculture tout
n'entre pas nécessairement dans une
colonne de chiffres c'est pour ça aussi
que l'âge en arrière de nous on a des
vieilles vaches que elles sont à la
retraite dans le fond elle produisent
plus puis oui elle pollue mais on les
aime puis si on fait ce métier là c'est
parce qu'on aime nos animaux enfin
qu'elle resteront là
[Musique]
de mon point de vue il faut qu'on si on
le ramène à l'échelle de l'entreprise
agricole il faut que ça nous motive à
réduire les émissions qui est vraiment
je pense le l'outil qu'on a le plus
concret aujourd'hui pour agir vers la
carbone neutralité réduire les gaz à
effet de serre c'est bon pour le climat
et bien souvent cela rend aussi les
fermes plus résilientes
plus de carbone dans le sol veut dire un
sol en meilleure santé qui s'adapte
mieux aux sécheresses par exemple les
producteurs sont parmi les premières
personnes affectées par l'évolution du
climatique et c'est pour ça que le
projet aussi émergé on parle de
changement climatique c'est moins chaud
de Boucan c'est des conditions qu'on
trouve à Port juste le 5 la veille on
avait des belles petites pluies d'été
[Musique]
millimètres ça nous surprend un peu
avant s'arrêter inimaginable des
sécheresses comme l'année passée c'était
un imaginable mais associé à ça des
gelés début juin ça c'est la vraie vie
des changements climatiques
jusqu'à producteur
ne peut être à la
la nouvelle réalité climatique les
agriculteurs auront à faire des choix et
à adapter leur entreprise et les
nouvelles connaissances feront partie de
la solution juste de s'informer puis
d'avoir accès à un bilan GES donc moi je
pense 50% du travail est déjà fait
[Musique]
de tout temps les agriculteurs ont tiré
leurs revenus de la vente de produits
agricoles des céréales des œufs du lait
de la viande mais pour la première fois
dans l'histoire une nouvelle source de
revenus potentiels apparaît à la ferme
posée de bons gestes pour
l'environnement peut désormais être
payant grâce au marché du carbone
[Musique]
c'est une journée bien occupée à la
ferme du producteur laitier Guillaume
faucher pendant qu'il multiplie les
passages au champ et garde un œil sur sa
première Coupe de foin
ailleurs sur sa terre une petite équipe
fait son entrée au chant car un autre
chantier se prépare le long de deux
cours d'eau dont la rivière Chaudière
800 arbres et plus de 300 arbustes
prendront racines les essences sont
variés des conifères des feuillus des
arbustes fruitiers et on ne laissera pas
le sol à nu ces graines se met à la
volée deviendront des fleurs qui
nourriront les pollinisateurs
donc on a deux rangées d'arbres
supplémentaires qui excèdent la
réglementation c'est une captation de
carbone en fait puis on vient augmenter
la bonne riveraine pour protéger un
petit peu plus le cours d'eau
en agriculture les bonnes riveraines
doivent atteindre au minimum trois
mètres à partir de la ligne des
hautes-aux cet espace qui n'est pas
cultivé est une sorte de bouclier qui
stabilise les rives et limite leur
ruissellement des engrais et des
pesticides ici les bandes riveraines
sont élargies à 8 mètres
un petit peu moins qu'un Hector en fait
qui est abandonné pour des bonnes
raisons d'énergie un peu moins d'un
hectare pour une terre qui en compte 220
qui gère la plantation il travaille pour
la Coopérative de solidarité arbres
évolution qui a lancé le programme
carbonner riverain on arrive à admettre
tous les morceaux ensemble pollinisation
ruissellement filtration
augmentation de la biodiversité il faut
comprendre que l'agriculteur lorsqu'on
fait une brise-vent ou qu'on élargit une
bonne riveraine c'est de la perte
d'espace cultivables donc c'est la perte
de revenu pour lui il faut absolument
trouver une façon de compenser
financièrement cette perte-là pour
chaque hectare convertit en bande
riveraine élargie les agriculteurs
reçoivent 22000 dollars la raison pour
laquelle on arrive à générer des sommes
d'argent pour compenser financièrement
l'agriculteur c'est à cause du marché du
marché volontaire du carbone dans le
cadre de ce marché des entreprises ou
des particuliers achètent volontairement
des crédits carbone pour compenser leurs
émissions de GES selon le programme
carbone riverain qui se base sur des
études faites dans le contexte québécois
chaque hectares de bandes riverain
élargies séquestruera un peu plus de
1500 tonnes de carbone sur 40 ans ici on
a le meilleur exemple c'est le papier
hybride lui c'est le champion
séquestrateur
après 40 ans on peut s'imaginer à une
bille de bois relativement grande en
échange de la compensation financière
les agriculteurs doivent signer une
servitude à perpétuité ça veut dire que
plus jamais le producteur agricole
essaie descendants vont pouvoir cultiver
plus près de la rivière que ça même si
la terre est vendue ou cédé ou légué les
prochains propriétaires devront
respecter l'entente un peu comme on voit
avec Hydro-Québec lorsqu'un pilon
électrique est implanté dans un sur une
terre agricole ont des dommages
agriculteurs on signe une servitude puis
le sureau aussi qui va être ajouté là
sûrement demain ou après-demain pour
Guillaume faucher qui est aussi
agroéconomiste ce projet offre un bon
compromis entre protection de
l'environnement et rentabilité en tant
que je suis prêt à si je veux protéger
mes cours d'eau c'est quand même un bien
public
je reconnais la valeur écologique de
tout ça mais un moment donné j'ai une
entreprise puis c'est mon gang pain puis
je peux pas assumer toutes les coups de
la protection de l'environnement pour
l'instant le prix des terres fait en
sorte qu'un programme de compensation
comme carbone riverain et plus
avantageux dans des régions où les
terres sont encore relativement
abordables la donne pourrait toutefois
changer car polluer coûtera de plus en
plus cher le prix de la tonne est voué à
augmenter ça pourra pas être moins que
22000 dollars hectares comme on donne
actuellement ça peut juste être plus
dans les prochaines années
les bandes riveraines ne sont pas
nouvelles on connaît leur bénéfice
depuis longtemps mais elles sont encore
trop peu respectées la citatif financier
sera peut-être la pièce qu'il manquait
pour qu'elle s'intègre de manière
durable dans le paysage agricole
ajoutez des arbres en bordure des champs
c'est une excellente façon de capter du
carbone mais ce n'est pas la seule le
sol sous nos pieds est un immense puit
de carbone sur lequel on mise de plus en
plus
en 2020 Kelly Garrett infirmier de liowa
a fait la manchette
il a récolté plus de 340 mille dollars
américains en devenant l'un des premiers
agriculteurs à vendre des crédits
carbone l'un des acheteurs le géant du
magazine âge Shopify la plateforme
canadienne voulait s'afficher comme
étant carbon neutre et l'agriculteur a
profité du fait que ces bonnes pratiques
comme les engrais verts permettaient de
conserver du carbone dans le sol c'est
1200 hectares de terre continuent
d’ailleurs d’accumuler du carbone et lui
rapporte encore plus de 50000 dollars
par année mais le sol étant un peu comme
une éponge il y a une limite à ce qu'il
peut emmagasiner et le maximum sera
bientôt atteint c'est certain que il
faut être très très prudent c'est à dire
qu'on peut recommander comme ça des
grandes pratiques qu'on sait qui sont
généralement bénéfiques pour les sols
Marie-Élise Samson une spécialiste des
sols de leur dire que on peut rétribuer
un agriculteur pour que une compagnie
puisse aller dépenser ce carbone là
ailleurs pour moi c'est sûr que je me
dis qu'il manque un peu de recherche il
faut qu'on développe encore nos
connaissances sur les seuls son domaine
d'études n'a jamais suscité autant
d'intérêt ça fait tout récemment un an
que je suis entré en poste comme
professeur et mon téléphone sonne sans
cesse que ce soit dans le gouvernement
qui veut mieux comprendre comment ça
fonctionne avant de prendre des
décisions que ça soit l'industrie aussi
qui va inviter dans la recherche par
rapport à la séquestration de carbone
dans les sols parce qu'ils sont
desireuses justement de d'avoir des
solutions pour acheter des tonnes et
carbone afin de pouvoir dire qu'ils sont
carbonade et donc oui on sent vraiment
un très très fort engouement au Québec
il n'existe pas encore de protocoles
reconnus pour que les agriculteurs
puissent tirer profit de réduction de
GES ou de quantité de carbone en
magasiné dans leur sol mais certains
travaillent à faire changer les choses
il accompagne les agriculteurs dans leur
transition climatique
la seule ou qui non seulement peut
diminuer ses gaz à effet de serre mais
peut retirer du CO2 d'atmosphère mais
séquestré dans les sols sous forme de
matière organique c'est la photo
s'intègre comme technologie de retraite
CO2 tu peux pas avoir plus simple que ça
et puis que ça c'est aucune technique à
côté ça
aujourd'hui il
rencontre la vallée et sa fille Pascale
c'est d'augmentation des taux de matière
organique dans le sol parce que chaque
fois qu'on retire par la photo
ça ça a une valeur extraordinaire dans
l'autre qu'on a des changements
climatiques mais si ça se monnaie c'est
un moment donné
est très sec pour nous
augmenter le taux de matière organique
c'est justement ce que tente de faire
les l'avaler dans ce champ de maïs
entre les rangs de maïs cette engrais
vert c'est ici du Trèfle du lait du
radis des plantes qui ne seront pas
récoltées mais qui vont apporter du
carbone et aussi de la vie dans le sol
c'est un changement total d'approche
pour les lavaliers qui mènent aussi en
parallèle une transition vers
l'agriculture biologique il y a quelques
années à peine il se battait pour garder
les entre-temps bien propres tel qu'on
les voit encore dans la majorité des
champs de maïs de la province
[Musique]
là il y a quelque chose de vraiment
extraordinaire qui est en train de se
passer ils agriculteurs vont à la fois
s'adapter aux changements climatique et
profiter d'un nouveau marché que jamais
existé avant la ferme des lavalie est
grande 1400 hectares réduire l'empreinte
carbone ici pourrait s'avérer payant
pour nous le projet de captation carbone
ça peut représenter plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de dollars par année donc ça
représente probablement le programme le
plus avantageux qui aurait en fait pour
les agriculteurs et en plus il y a des
avantages à nous permettre
d'améliorer notre qualité de sol
d'améliorer notre matière organique dans
le sol en semant les engrèveurs en les
enfouissant et en travaillant avec la
terre les matières organiques l'une des
clés pour amener du carbone dans le sol
c'est de le couvrir au maximum
de trèfle une coupe
il devrait pas avoir un mètre carré de
terrain de sol agricoles qui est pas
utilisé par une culture pour faire de la
photosynthèse tant que le climat puis le
température le permet c'est sa
diversifie les cultures on en a
d'ailleurs un bel exemple dans ce champ
le blé vient tout juste d'être récolté
et on voit déjà une belle repousse de
trèfle une légumineuse entre les rangs
comme toutes les légumineuses c'est
l'équivalent d'une micro-usine d'engrais
azoté ces plantes arrivent à capter
l'azote de l'air et en faire un
fertilisant disponible pour la culture
suivante tout ça sans les émissions de
GES qui viennent normalement avec les
engrais chimiques on pratique pas
l'agriculture aujourd'hui comme on l'a
pratiqué il y a 10 ans je pense pas que
dans disait on va la pratiquer comme on
la pratique aujourd'hui mais la tendance
est quand même lourde pour prendre plus
conscience à l'environnement mais si les
sculpteurs veulent être rétribués pour
le carbone qu'il garde dans leur sol ça
pose quand même un défi car il faut
mesurer ses augmentations de matière
organique cela se fait avec des analyses
de sol mais pour avoir un portrait
fidèle il en faut beaucoup ce qui coûte
cher non même si le coût de l'analyse
est très élevé est-ce que ça peut être
quand même financièrement avantageux
pour le producteur ben ça ça va dépendre
du prix de l'atome donc le coût de
l'atome de carbone il faut pas que la
mise en place de cette comptabilité là
soit tellement dispendieuse que la
valeur que ça a enlève à l'agriculteur
la valeur de ces crédits compensatoires
éventuels l'autre enjeu c'est que les
changements mis en place par les
agriculteurs devront être permanents
dans des projets comme ça il faut que
s'engage sur le long terme sinon on peut
pas parler de séquestration de carbone
et donc ça veut dire que le producteur
ne peut pas décider qui rechange de
pratique plus tard sinon il y a des
chances pour que c'est un des carbone
dépensé par l'industrie finissent par
être émises quand même aussi par le sol
mais n'y a-t-il pas un danger déco
blanchiment que les bonnes pratiques des
agriculteurs servent en fait à des fins
de marketing pour verdir le blason de
certaines industries on peut pas juste
se dire on va continuer la vie comme
elle est et séquestrer du carbone dans
les sols et voilà la solution pas du
tout en fait il faut que la
séquestration de carbone dans les sols
soit vu pour tous ces coups bénéfices
aussi au niveau de l'agriculture la
durabilité de nos systèmes puis il faut
que ce soit vu comme un outil pour la
transition vers des énergies plus vertes
donc il va falloir de toute façon
réduire nos émissions réduire à la fois
nos émissions et tenter de renverser une
tendance
à 50 ans qu'on brûle la matière
organique dans nos pratiques
on est du capable de trouver réellement
ça c'est tout un défi c'est sûr que ça
sera pas facile
[Musique]